these two radio astronomers working at a
t Bell Labs that's where the first radio
transmitters first cell phones were
invented they were looking up at the
satellite that had been launched at
great cause which is the only satellite
it was the only internet in 1965 they
got some signals you know they were
getting there but it was extremely
unreliable low bandwidth terrible they
couldn't figure out why is the noise so
hot they had a model for how their
telescope their receiving instruments
should behave and it was totally
crapping out not because of anything in
the instrument but because of the cosmos
itself the cosmos was raining down
static noise that static is coming from
the origin is that what that really is
coming from